en 2010 est le candidat macron avait
promis de sauver france ô aujourd'hui
président il se ravise et déclare que la
chaîne de télévision du service public
n'est pas indispensable elle va donc
disparaître le 23 août prochain
décision validée la semaine dernière par
la ministre de la culture
le choix de la supprimer a provoqué la
colère d'élus et d'associations
ultramarins il dénonce une décision
uniquement financière une trentaine de
salariés si elle doit être reclassés par
france télévisions écoutez à ce sujet
l'analyse de daniel dalin un président
du conseil représentatif des français
originaires d'outre-mer et président du
collectifdom le président de la
république lors de son le candidat macro
lors de son de son passage devant la
communauté ultra-marine juste avant les
élections nous allons nous a regardé
droit dans les yeux nous a juré que
france ô ne devra pas disparaître du
paysage audiovisuel français
nous l'avons cru lorsque nous savons
très bien que france ô si françois ne
marche pas on n'a pas bien fonctionné
c'est juste parce que ce sont des choix
politiques qui ont toujours vous qui
n'ont jamais été à ceux qui n'ont jamais
été clair au début que france ô cité la
chaîne d outre-mer après c'est devenu la
chaîne de la diversité et tout le monde
sait que le terme diversité c'est le
fourre tout où on peut tout mettre ou
françois parler de tout de tout ce qui
n'était pas puisqu'ils n'étaient pas
français en couleur blanc de peau et
julien l'afrique le madagascar tout ça
il ya c'était la chaîne foot et quand
une chaîne parle de tout c'est la chaîne
ne vient une chaîne qui n'intéresse
personne en fait